hi I think having so I'm going to talk
to you my name is Damon Cola I'm going
to talk today about my book how they
either spread which came out this summer
was taking University of crest this book
is based on about a decade of work and
none of the papers and they talked about
recently or published in science and NES
and the American Journal of sociology
said you can I'll grab some of those
references for you after those people
are interested in thinking more about
this problem and this talk is kind of an
overview a high-level description of a
lot of the a lot of the topics that are
dealt with and obviously much more
detail in the book and the main thing
that I want to think about it and you
know encourage you to think about is
when we think about any kind of
behavioral contagion process there's
obviously some kind of contact mama we
have underneath that and we tend to
interpret that in the space of social
network so we even image like this in
our mind so we imagine there's some
pattern of connectedness in a population
and when we think about some behavior
change spreading it's sort of cascading
from person to person to network and we
think about they're sort of deep
properties of the network we tend to
pick out these elements like the very
highly connected people these are
referred to as hubs or social stars
versions of people in the periphery who
are more modestly connected but they
tend to be surely embedded in incomes of
clustered communities and we think about
social change dynamics some of the more
popular things that we have data on now
that we can talk about our ethical
chains and large definition movements
like Arab Spring and this network data
that is extracted from our clips or
Twitter and one of the things that was
remarkable by our experience how it
spread through social media networks in
a way that was relatively traceable we
think about how that spreading process
might have looked there's a very
intuitive model from disease
transmission when we say well it
probably happened there was someone at
some point to as a hub who became
activated that sort of highly popular
activist and then that person would then
you know mobilize their friends and
contact that
familiy imagine really spreading one
sort of takes off from an activist hub
then it would diffuse from kind of the
core of the network to reach other core
members then from them out further
towards the periphery and then
ultimately to the saturating the network
and we have this kind of you know from
the course that for a free model
diffusion which is very intuitive when
we think about disease spreading and
it's also fairly natural to think about
it your information and behavior
spraying in the same way what you see
about Arab Spring is that we actually
have extremely good data and so
colleague of mine at UCLA Zack Ryder he
did put a confinement he spent the you
know five years in cetaceans just corn
over the Arab Spring data in particular
looking at Egypt and the mobilisation
there and the first thing he noticed was
that the mobilization didn't really
apparently start in those highly
connected poor actors it said it's in
the periphery and the wave spread is
doing more interesting it kind of past
dated around from the peripheral nodes
and then kept sort of growing around the
cursor I notice neither of the two hubs
are activated at this point finally at
some point one of the hubs become sort
of mobilized so one of the other hubs
isn't and many of the entire network is
become activated by virtue of a kind of
you know splitting around the periphery
process now this really could have
motivates for us if I'm empirical coming
over on the one hand you've got the sort
of network on the left that describe how
we said intuitively think of diffusion
from our view your viable model
perspective which is a highly connected
people are the speed spreaders and
everything spread outward from them
versus what the data actually look like
which is that we tend to see a lot of
different spreading in the periphery and
then it kind of ultimately reaches the
center so what I want to do in this talk
is that I really invite you to think
about your intuitions about how networks
control diffusion as hope to start off
the conversation I'm going to actually
go right for the question of intuition
this is our an image that of two tables
that there you go that it is used by
some commentator in their book nudge and
what they're trying to do which is
playable
is elicit kind of a kind of common sense
idea about which of the two tables is
longer and it's clear that if you look
at the ratio of rank so with obviously
the table on the left is longer but in
fact it's a trick question if you look
at the tables around turned up the same
table and you know the cognitive
psychologists separate explains this in
terms of the perspective played by the
table and the contrast fitted by the
legs and their generations illusion and
if you need some more convincing
evidence we can show you that if you
take the radius of a circle and make it
the width of the table and then draw the
circumference that it actually bisects
the lanes in both cases in other words
the ratio is two to one in both cases
and I can explai it to you you know from
a cognitive triple psychology point of
view and I thought to also give you a
proof mathematically and here's a point
the point is now that you have this new
scientific theory of mind the question
is if you were to look at between a look
at new data now with this new theory in
mind would you then see the world
differently and so there's your question
if you look if I ask you to look at your
tables which one is longer and the point
is that despite knowing the right answer
to plate having a new scientific
information in your head you
nevertheless have the same intuition
within should have gut response to the
images you had before and I want to
suggest the kind of persistent illusion
which shows up in you know kind of in
potential psychology and now in behavior
economics our time is actually also
fairly prevalent in networks research
and the most common question we ask in
networks when this is in sociology
computer science you know physics
applied math like the basic question is
how does the pattern of connectedness in
the society affect excusing their cost
it nothing really Santa's answer was
published 1973 called the strength of
weak ties and this events become kind of
a one of the foundational ideas for all
of network science as basically the idea
that you've got some people that you
know was published by manometers
especially there in the sociology
department at Stanford
and you know what he was interested in
was kind of the difference between our
close friends the people that we know
really well Perkins or the casual
acquaintances and he made this really
interesting observation that people we
know really well often seem to know each
other which means the level of aspect in
our social ties all supposed to be
correlated with the structure of those
plies the people that we trust and that
we have known a long time that we can
interact with frequently also tend to
know each other's version is the casual
acquaintances and people to eat you know
at a party or at a conference
you might exchange the information with
them you might learn about like a new
type of shipping system or you might
learn about a new kind of app from them
but you wouldn't ask to you know for a
large sum of money from them because
they're basically strangers
glenda that are point out that those
people because your close ties don't
know any of their close ties those kinds
of casual acquaintances actually are
fairly important because the ashes and
wads I think bridges that basically fan
the social network and so the core
intuition here is that weak ties they're
actually long distance ties and
therefore from a diffusing perspective
they're quite important and they allow
new ideas information and behaviors to
find jump across the network and
therefore spread out this idea was then
formalized in a small world model bike
he forgot some dark and walks the core
idea is then sort of particularly
actually originally in Granovetter paper
it's the same idea that people believe
today wasn't that whatever has to be
diffused means a large room people in
Traverse a greater personal distance one
passively tides rise and strong so with
that in mind I want you to look at these
two net with images and sort of think
intuitively what's of these two images
they sort of the better neighborhood
technology for fast diffusion and
clearly the network on the Left it's
green speed it looks like something that
you know anyone in that neighborhood
gets activated they activate the hub and
then everyone else you know gets
activated which isn't the right-hand
network of used to kind of percolate
very slowly from neighbor to neighbor to
get you the entire community and the
point of the book in really their
theoretical arguments have been
developing over the last ten years is
that
the the viral model clearly works better
in the left-hand Network and it's true
for information too
but when it comes to swimming behavior
but across very difficult actually the
network on the right it's going to be
much more effective for spreading them
quickly and this hasn't fairly like
striking counter intuitive prediction
one of which is that if you were to
build a community on the internet and
they structure that community or any way
you could you might actually prefer the
structure like a network on the right
rather than network on the left in order
to generate fast diffusion and I'll
present to you today the results in
experiment there's publishing science
where we did this that and the results
are strikingly clear that the network on
the right is actually the better one for
diffusion so the question here is our
intuition is what goes wrong what goes
wrong is that this sort of basic idea in
epidemiology that exposure we've been
spreading and then that works well for
viruses when it comes to behavior change
the way that people interact and this
worm reinforcement they have for the
behaviors they adopt actually that is a
lot more than just whether or not they
were exposed to something interestingly
these features of intuition to lead us
astray even in situations where people
have thought about the topic a lot so
people know Malcolm Bravo was a book
called a tipping point and in 2010 he
did is to name a book and I'm convinced
for ideas and behaviors and new products
move through a population very much like
a TV stars this is the metaphor number
words I'm talking about a very literal
analogy this we contagion exactly the
same way that a virus
well that way of thinking about
diffusion of course was also talked
about by my colleague here John Berger
in the book on pages where the kind of
the kind of viral model of just making
something as contagious as possible is
the core idea for thinking about
diffusion and now contrast that with
something else I will wrote also in the
very same year in 2010 or an article in
New Yorker I'm on Arab Spring but social
revolution more generally and he said
look even revolutionary actions that
look spontaneous but the demonstrations
needs Germany led to the fall of the
Berlin Wall coarse rhonchi phenomenon
the primary determinant he showed up was
critical friends the more friends you
had were critical of the regime the more
likely you were to join the protest the
important point here is that Gladwell
contradicting himself that
quote is going pulling out that left
hand network that like weak tie
radiating network that's the best
network for diffusion but the bottom
quote is actually pulling out the right
hand network the kind of clustered you
know locally connected neighborhood
network as the better network for
diffusion goggle doesn't realize he's
contradicting himself
here however because the epidemiological
intuition is so basic that appears as
though when he say it's consistent but
the point of this sort of way of
unpacking the problem is to realize that
even when we think we know what we're
looking at these illusions can
nevertheless and then to that we're
seeing some things that we're not seeing
so what I'm going to do if the talk has
really shown you there aquaria the weak
ties intuition and then to show you once
you really understand that how badly it
goes wrong and then the sort of the main
theoretical explanation years and
there's a fundamental difference between
simple contagion like viruses and
complex contagions like behaviors ones
I'll explain that in detail and then
I'll DaVinci Network experiments and so
if the implications are there from
failing like new kinds of policy and
these new kinds of stuff architecture is
really online they can harness these
ideas to promote the spread of behavior
case so maybe a little bit of periodical
background talk about the experiment the
implications for social design the
theoretical background here really
starts with the notion of social network
this is a really rudimentary figure the
idea that people use the term different
the devil in computer science want to
think about large-scale network
authorities the important thing to know
is if there are still from people many
actually in social science who use this
notion of a network the problem with
this notion of a network is that you
can't really infer anything about
diffusion beyond Bob neighborhood bob
has some ties but you don't know you
know what what the influence of Madison
Bob is or what that is what that means
for any heart spreading beyond Box
neighborhood important is renovator
pointed out you may be able to sort of
get some correlations between Madison's
behavior and Bob's behavior but actually
if you really want to know what the
influence is that someone like Madison
on Bob you need to know what the
connections are in Bob's Network not
just who bothers connected to you but
who his friends are connected to it's
Madison that's here and are both
connected to each other that means they
can coordinate they can in fact collude
they can pressure box we got the
behavior
targeting management here in auto it's
not actually part of Bob's immediate
neighborhood it is actually also a
factor in determining how people can
crush your Bob also it Bob - Cynthia
Shona and Shawn is not connected to any
of us with their friends in Shawn as a
weak price like alliances went to a
different part of the social space the
Sean Astin's in the port in conduit for
new ideas information behaviors in the
Box neighborhood of course the way we
look at it now is this wooden step from
the you know friends bunch of friends
all the way out but it's a large scale
macro structures of social network those
images tend to be visually not very
informative but statistically obviously
we can learn a lot from them the idea is
to take these new methods from math and
statistics but the core intuition that
we can use the structure of the social
network the real topological properties
of the network and thereby infer
something about collective behavior
actually dates back to demos work in
1908 it's actually a very old idea of
sociology we just now have what really
powerful new Malthus can make sense of
it and so quiet I wanted the core sort
of models that we use these days is
called the small world model so many
people in the room hopefully have seen
that the Dodgers represent people the
lines represent you know relationships
and the basic idea is that this is a
potential for to exploit model it's a
very simplistic representation of a
social network it's not meant to be
realistic which meant to do is capture
the corsa typical properties that govern
diffusion dynamic and those things
physical properties then authors show up
in every empirical social network that
you look at and so on you identify what
these properties are and then you can
get a really nice grip on even very
complex networks so when the left is
basically a geographic lattice Network
within one dimensional network but that
important point about it is that each
person has two neighbors and left and
chambers and they're right they've
shared neighbors basically triangle you
know friends of friends know each other
there's not a clustering that's the
technical term for that in a network the
important question we typically ask
about this from a diffusion perspective
is how many handshake does it take to
get from one person to another person in
the network so for instance in that
storm tide network with lots of
clustering you know to get a
the populations on the side get to go
through every intervening neighborhood
not the network is very large talking
about with a million people the number
of steps yet to go through a number of
handshakes get across it is on the order
of the size of the network so that means
if you're looking at Mike and network
with a million nodes you're talking
about hundreds of thousands of steps to
get from any one person to anyone else
that's very very slow from the diffusion
perspective so the model this is called
a permutation model it's a very kind of
clever mathematical trick where what you
do is you break some of the local ties
and the wire then paste basically
creating these shortcuts across the
social space and the far right hand side
we were wired almost all of them ties
and created which there's an asking for
small world network and now what's
interesting about it is it the same
number of ties with indenting the
network but if we ask the same question
about you know degrees of separation how
many steps to get across it
now it's on the order of log of the size
of the network which means that a
million knows you're talking about
basically six steps where the notion of
six degrees of separation comes from is
that you dramatically reduce the number
of steps being across the population
despite changing this configuration now
this of course has huge implications for
diffusion so if I show you the
simulation that uses the same networks I
just showed you the network on the Left
named lattice they're just looking at
everyone has neighbors in the
neighborhoods at four and they're
overlapping the white nodes are so
people haven't adopted a TD they're the
kind of early adopters and the rules of
social simple contagion rule so if one
of your neighbors have got them you also
I got and when you see is it certainly
spreads or on the structure of the
ladder
Senate from neighborhood to neighborhood
and then ultimately it sort of you know
cascades around and saturates our
population of it next thing we want to
look at is what happens when we add some
of these long-distance ties into the
network so why is it happening is that
the contagion now can sort of jump
across these long-distance links and
then fan out very quickly across the
network now on the far right hand side
we have tons of weak ties they're
randomly something all over the network
and now what happens the contagion
process is dramatically accelerated it
can you know very quickly jump across
population this is this kind of core
idea from strength of weak ties and
small world is that weak ties facilitate
the fusion random that works your burger
clustered network so all of that is to
set up the basic viral intuition and now
what I want to do is show you like
really how it fails and the reason is
failed vest is because that viral
intuition doesn't take into account the
fact that when we're making decisions
that are difficult we tend to need to be
convinced in some way to make that
decision so macadam demagogues are also
a sociologist there at Stanford he has
some very important work on Freedom
Summer which was one of the current kind
of pivotal social movement or social
movement events in the civil rights
movement and in study recruitment for
freedom summer which is very dangerous
people were killed participating in it
nevertheless people that participated he
said the fact that we are embedded in
many relationships means that any major
decision we are concentrating is like we
needed by significant subset of those
relationships to be pulling out
different scene seeing a behavior
annoying it's an option for me having a
sufficient number of people adopt the
behavior they convinced me about that as
well write a simple contagion like the
measles means that you know if anyone of
my network has a measles and I have
proper contact with them I'll get
infected but if I'm trying to you know
consider adopting you know vacation in
our social movement that's dangerous
that could involve imprisonment or
potential you know harm or even death
it's not just because I see someone
who's adopted isn't going to convince me
the job actually needs strong social
reinforcement both the things are going
to save and also to convince me it's
something that you know I should do and
the more that we think about it and why
do we realize that there's lots of
reasons why behavior change requires
social reinforcement for multiple
sources so only amplifies the core
difference here is that a simple
contagion oneis contact with a single
source and repeated contact with that
source leads to higher probability of
transmission there's the same person the
Keynesians that they keep interacting
with you eventually will transmit the
measles
but the whole point out of complexity is
that one person they're getting again
and again is not enough you need
multiple sources of contact to convince
you and now we want to think about why
that's the case well one reason is
credibility even if one person is people
you serve in our technology you know
lots of other people who aren't so what
you really need to see is that several
people are adopting that technology and
it's a numbers that really make it
credible and a similar kind of thing is
legitimacy where you know legitimacy
really is when you think about any kind
of behavior that's kind of contentious
or that there's some kind of social norm
involved you're also paying attention to
the people who have not about it right
they're not adopters of this kind of
counter billing influences keeping you
in a status quo just because one
person's adopted the behavior that's
certainly not a reason to do it like
you've got a lot of you know the balance
of evidence against that behavior but
now when you get more and more
reinforcing adopters that actually
counter that ways again the counter
billing influences up not adopters so
another kind of reason why we need
multiple sources of reinforcement
legitimacy finally complementarity of
course this is the big one you know in
Silicon Valley is anything to do with
social media you know the value of the
technology changes the number of people
using it you can think about any kind of
social media platform out there or any
communication technology really just
because one person is using it you know
you have contact with it doesn't make it
valuable the more people who are using a
platform the more inherently valuable
platform is and these are all different
kinds of reasons it's kind of a
legitimacy complementarity emotional
excitement is another one these are all
kinds of you know situations basically
in which adoption of a kind of foreign
or unusual or costly behavior requires a
point of social reinforcement of course
we want to know is if this is true
there's a big difference you can point
simple and complex contagion why is it
matter for diffusion so that's what you
want to see when it takes the original
Network model we were just looking at my
world model and see if we add in the
need for social reinforcement for a
second from a second source yet that
does the diffusion dynamic so first I
played it in the lattice which is a team
lattice we were looking at before
again the white noise is not adopted
children learn to the innovators but the
only difference here the people need
social reinforcement from a second
neighbor before they all about and when
you watch this spread the spreading
process looks kind of like before but
little slower everyone's waiting for
that second source of reinforcement
before they adopt but ultimately its own
spreads from neighborhood neighborhood
kind of spilling over and then testing
her on the lattice so now super complex
contagion spread so much more slowly
along the lattice in the simple
contagion the actual room for
improvement by absence by adding these
long distant cries is much greater so
the relative gain here is to be striking
when we add someone's in 2002 Network
soap a very you know this looks like
very carefully to see what happens this
is all that happens the contagion starts
to spread and they hit the neighborhood
were tied to been rewired and all of a
sudden basically the rewiring with highs
has eroded the underlies the
reinforcement structure the network
there's insufficient social pressure to
carry the behavior from one neighborhood
the next to see them up close you can
take a look an individual a and age
neighbor cocoon left on the right and
B&Bs neighbors turn left on the right
and this is common over to shared
friends now the key point here is it's a
common neighbors they can create a wide
bridge multiple reinforcement ties from
one neighborhood to the other so in
almost all the network classes or the
ecology classes or grassy or toxic
taking people talk about pathways they
talk about bridges but what the
assumptions throughout is that a single
tie is sufficient for a bridge but what
this work does is that actually changes
that entire logic of what a bridge means
and what a path length is because for
complex contagion it's not just the
length of the bridge which is the
differences man please help me win the
bridge separations if you're to rewire
the network here and have a have a tie
for our way and be the PI far away
now you notice there still a link
between the two neighborhoods there's
still a single common neighbor then what
that means there's still a bridge
between the neighborhood but it can now
it's a narrow bridge so disease can
still spread between the neighborhoods
and information can so bright red boots
between neighborhoods
those intimate social reinforcement of
India's friends about that costly or
difficult or unusual or illegitimate
behavior it's not going to spread to the
edgiest friends and to the punchline
here is that if we're interested in the
spread of viruses and you know the
classic the project Network models work
very well but as soon as were interested
in the spread of contagions that are
difficult or costly or require some
level legitimacy any kind of political
contagion any kind of health contagion
right any of the contagion that we think
of as like interesting in a social
science point of view anything that
requires some thinking to understand why
it would spread then it's going to be a
complex contagion these kinds of
dynamics are going to matter a lot
there's a bunch of papers and the
students indicate the finished paper
there are bunch papers in the general
members will say yeah sociology of the
American Civil physiology and what they
do is they for the robustness of these
results so of course I just showed you a
very stylized set of models right idea
threshold of warn versus threshold were
to the networks were you know these
really stylized you know circular
lattices that were required you can a
permutation model so you have lots of
questions if you want to know about what
happens with no degree distributions
what happens with threshold
distributions what happens to special
the probabilistic what happens if you
introduce actual high strength that is
the model
what happened that their status
differences in the model right these are
all really good questions and in fact up
with those all these papers of any case
we're dressing them and of course the
chapter in the book that introduces this
then spend a lot of time in the papers
are technical that talk about the
results of the model you know in a
modeling and formal way but in the book
I describe each of these results in
these new kinds of robustness test
initiative and contextual way with
examples and what winds up coming out of
it I think it's so important is that the
more realistic you make this model the
more kind of empirical detail and
heterogeneity and permeability you add
into it the more that the diffusion of
complex engages depend on why bridges
the more importantly topological effects
are and so this means that that small
world
every stylized where model is actually
the best case scenario for the strength
of weak ties as you can get more
realistic actually the effects of
accomplishing agents become more
dominant and so we can see what that
means here for instance in this kind of
network that I was talking about at the
beginning where you've gotten or some
huggsy some crystal knows so we had the
social stardom and a crook or actor now
from a simple contagion point of view
obviously the intuition is that well the
simple you know the simple contagion
node in the center of the hub is in a
very easily detect that there's
something in the network so in to be
activated very early on because they've
got something going high they can easily
survey the population of course and that
person becomes activated and they become
the massive conduit for spreading to
everybody else so that's why some are
clear bio intuition so the question is
why doesn't that work for complex
contagion well what's going on with a
complex contagion particularly any kind
of behavior where legitimacy is involved
so you can think here about like a
fortune 500 manager is deciding whether
or not to adopt like uh a new and
somewhat controversial new management
strategies well you might detect it
early on because she has you know a
fairly tinted network so she'll see that
that management strategies out there
before other people will but it also
means that if she adopts it right away
do you like can look a little bit
reckless he's adopting a really perfect
you know contentious or controversial
new strategy the forest improvement and
so he needs to be aware of the fact that
all those eyes she has
aren't just outgoing vehicles for her to
influence there are also incoming tides
of judgment these are all people who are
very aware of what she's doing and she's
got very very strong reputation effects
like a lot of people want to know that
she's making good decisions and so a
highly connected person for this reason
is often one of the laughs adopters for
any kind of contentious or unfamiliar a
new kind of innovation because they are
under so much scrutiny
whereas the people on the right hand
network in a clustered Network have far
fewer ties until you can be of someone
like a menace dollar company who gets
exposed
new management strategy and basically
with this just a few contacts they can
have a strong level of reinforcement in
their immediate neighborhood and then a
dot and this is why we see as we saw an
Arab Spring so many of these kinds of
contagion class he's growing the
periphery was much easier to get kind of
a small critical mass off the ground
because you just don't have as many
countervailing influences pressuring
people to sort of wait and be
conservative and in fact what's
interesting is that the more studies you
look at basically in the decades and and
first published this work there's been
Studies on bullying interventions in
schools the adoption of Twitter and
Facebook this is like actually people
coming up for account social
mobilization on Twitter so the spread of
like critical hashtags and Arab Spring
and then I'll say to the cheese of
innovations like the Equality sign which
was support for same-sex marriage for
across Facebook common Lada Adamic he's
a former Stanford person who now works
at Facebook did a really beautiful an
extensive study because she of course
had all the data of how a contentious
social movement spread across and I
think just over a week 3 million people
changed their Facebook profile to
support same-sex marriage that's open
that's a largest diffusion process and
Facebook history it sounds like it's
viral but actually her analysis and the
papers published showed that the
confrontation and diffused in this way
of like multiple reinforcing kind of
peripheral networks growing into it
became a very popular thing and in the
central North adopted and to the point
that these these studies are often
different literature's but they're all
identifying the same basic dynamics
which are the dynamics of conference
engages so in the book I talk about
these implications for hub for
organizational thinking for Heather
structure you know for brokers across
different groups so the implications for
design thinking why emphasis I know in
the b-school in other places is think
about products is the most important
thing if you just design the perfect
product
you know it'll spread and there's a
whole section in the book talking about
that fallacy which is basically they've
been shown time and time again by
growing art for among others that
a superior better design better marketed
innovation and awesome sales and the
inferior one often wears and the idea
that you can just make something
perfectly contagious and you know
Express fail to comprehend that a lot of
the reasons why he adopt things have to
do with what other people are doing not
doing the project itself and of the
success of VHF versus Betamax the
success of QWERTY versus more than
keyboards the success they play whatever
she's heavy water nuclear reactors all
of these things are based on network
effects they kind of triggered social
reinforcement and that was a more
important more decisive factor for
spreading of innovations and the actual
quality of the innovation or the
marketing around it
and then of course is also have
implications for social media and how we
use it so what I want to talk about that
is what what we can do now thinking
about the sort of online space what we
can build just shows us how effective
this model is if people have thought for
you know really since Granovetter
grandmother's are the first people to
write a paper saying we should try to
test these models theoretic you know
experimental ii or at least you know get
data any kind of data to test them and
if it's not that people haven't been
trying for 50 years to do this it's just
like data haven't existed yet very large
scale de fine-grained longitudinal data
I'm like who adopted in one and you also
need to be a brutally producible think
about this very sort of obvious but at
the same time it should painful fact
when you lead all of your studies on
sort of large-scale network data if
you're studying is a fusion process you
have a hundred thousand people connect
to the network how many data points you
have
if you're setting a diffusion process
you have one data point which is the
diffusion process there one hundred
thousand people are all interdependent
as part of that one process so
reproducibility for any kind of
collective behavior is if a population
level not the individual level do a unit
of observation is a population so you
can think of it you know this way to you
take a look at this for the cooling
video and you see these twenty thousand
fish moving around
I know it's if it's tilted there on the
video for you but you can see make it as
a schooling process and the question is
if here is thirty to twenty thousand
fish
visually and look at them one more time
could you ever infer this collective
behavior could you figure out how to
intervene to disrupt it or how to
intervene to accelerate it the answer of
course is no to what I understand is
collected spooling process need to study
school for fish and that is exactly I
think the truth of human populations as
well you want to understand what you
know how traffic jams emerge or how
large-scale riots emerge or how match
the patterns and welcomed equality
emerged we need to send the collective
dynamic but leave some micro to macro
and that is in fact what we're able to
be now with large scale in an experiment
this this idea experimental physiology
which again I talked about in the book
is there as a way of thinking about
really about studying populations the
way that the same way that we study kind
of you know forgive the pun there's so
many study cultures in the lab right so
the idea that we can create two
populations that are identical in every
way and change one feature about
president population in this case
imagine change the network structure and
as a result of that growing systemic
behavior change in one population and
shown that it just doesn't happen the
other one if you can do that if you can
sub you can systematically generate
you've collected the differences in
collective behavior by virtue of the
structure of the population that's
replicable and once it's replicable then
you're very very close to policy you're
close to being able to say that I can
generate collective behavior in a
systematic fashion by changing these
features in the population this is
obviously very painful thinking about
social media for me I wanted to design a
study where I could basically examine
these kind of processes the diffusion
constant on behaviors that were real
behaviors other words they didn't want
to pay people to come to an experiment
give them $10 to show up and then study
what they do and don't do in this like
really artificial setting what I wanted
to do was find something that people
were already doing like basic field
experiments and then build my own you
know product in the space of whatever
you know domains before using so you can
imagine doing this with like an online
shopping network you can do this with
online invest
network I want a billion Health Network
and I describe my my thinking process in
the book basically in terms of the
defense that I notice the people who are
joining these are my health sceneries
and there are millions effort
we're remarkably eager to like
participate with other people in them
you know upload their upload their
health information and shadow of your
private sector HIPAA protected like
private health data with strangers and
then to take the advice of strangers and
leave it to help influence their own
behavior and noticing that and for me
became a really remarkable vehicle for
thinking about how to build a space
where you could recruit thousands of
people so about two thousand people
signed up for this team they're built
and they were all you know they weren't
being paid they just showed up and join
because of their inherent interest in
learning about health resources for
themselves but then I couldn't been sign
them health buddies in this space who
are anonymous and more basically you
know just people that they were
interacting with but the beauty of that
which means I could control what that
Network look like and if that control
would be very natural people wouldn't
perceive anything we are the
manipulative about the social
environment so it'd be this kind of
invisible expand and where you would
really just have people doing something
normal but in the background would have
manipulated it so really is in a true I
think if it were a field experiment so
when people find out they of course
agreed for informed consent that's an
important to the ethical issue with any
data collection so people knew that they
were in a study but then you know the
real sort of special thing that happened
is that then people are randomized to
conditions so the black node in both of
these networks shows individual who is
being randomized and the red nodes show
that person's neighbors because in the
left hand network the person who's being
randomized has four neighbors who are
all kind of like in a clustered
neighborhood they're just appended to
each other
well the right hand network the
randomized no it has four neighbors who
are randomly dispersed all over the
network and none of them are neighbors
at each other so I'm a kind of
psychology point of view from our first
person point of view these two
conditions but identical both people see
that they have four neighbors they can't
see the rest
network just see their immediate you
know health buddies so what's
interesting is that the hypothesis here
is that the structure of the network
even though it's invisible to everyone
in all conditions nevertheless will
control the behavior and will control it
in predictable ways Benson etherion
complex engages so people then choose
like a username and then sees an avatar
and represent themselves and they choose
some health interest but sexual think
they care about the reason for being in
the community and then the end of the
signup process what they see they see
themselves their avatars and their
health interest and of course the
avatars and their health interest of
their health buddies and then what I do
is I build up basically the dependent
variable is another product they built
their a kind of a community sharing
forum called the health forum but people
couldn't you know rate and share health
resources with each other and the
question was if I diffused that
technology through these networks where
each time someone adopted I notified
them and say hey one of their health but
he signed up for the tell forum I could
then watch the sort of adoption pattern
as the health forms bridge these social
networks and my hypothesis was that
connectedness of these networks can
control the rate and the overall success
of these of that innovation diffusion
progress so you can see here and you
know a network where a bunch of people
have not adopted yet and I introduced
actually I just use one speed and then I
watched it spread to the entire
population so I'm going to skip instead
of giving you all of the details of
Jenner described in the book I wanted to
cut to the results so a lot of people
spend a lot of time giving your large
statistics and P values one of the
nicest things about doing a very clean
internet experiment is that the data
themselves are beautiful
until via I can just show you something
people never be allowed to say the raw
data this is literally just the pine
theories of what people did to the left
hand that was 128 people in a clustered
network and the right hand networks 128
people in a random network the blue node
of course is the person here than in our
seeds and when people adopt but you'll
see it the links light up and that's
very important it allows you to see
the messages are going that allows you
kind of see how fast people are finding
out about this sort of Health Forum
innovation and of course will actually
adopt they turn blue you can see the
contagion process the took three weeks
in real time but here it's rescale but
you know next to each other they're
comparable real-time so you can see
there's a random network is that early
on a people adopt the links of course
are random so they're all over the
network so very quickly word of the
innovation spreads everywhere and this
is the power of weak ties the power of
small word world is that you get very
quick information diffusion but it's not
really translating into adoption where
he's looking left-hand Network weather
then ties are kind of clustered in local
neighborhood sharing lots of redundancy
that redundancy is wasteful for
information diffusion people already
heard about it but it's very effective
for behavioral diffusion ever done this
we basically create very effective
patterns of behavior change where people
are you know convinced to adopt the
innovation and so what you want to
notice it's like they're really distinct
pattern of adoption in a question
network for some random network and then
think about what that means when you
replicate it so I ran six files with the
same exact design and this is 1500 1528
hearing beings but it's only 12 data
points for the reasons I described
earlier which is that each person area
network is interdependent so the unit of
observation is the network and what's
remarkable reducing you know taking this
the statistical power 1500 data points
putting it knowing 12 you nevertheless
get remarkably clear result is that in
every single case the behavior spread
more people in the clustered networks
and this went faster than expected
network so this is a direct
contradiction of the entire should have
strength of weak ties pieces but
remember you've got it at least out of
here here there's a reason why we expect
to see this in the reasons of course we
think this social reinforcement will
make behavior change more likely and of
course what we see and we look at the
individual level
you see even the COS portion or hazard
model people are much more likely to
adopt when they get a second
signal versus just one Ashley there were
significant markets without getting
three signals and just to to reinforce
them actually in a big different
adoption the people like a science came
out in 2010 and one of the things that
reviewers asked was well you know you've
shown the dynamics of diffusion and
insert but what about commitment that's
a really good question because I hadn't
really been thinking about commitment by
in that you know any context whether
it's you know product adoption or
whether it's you know a health behavior
you're interested in whether someone's
r6 with it after they initially adopt it
you can kind of abandoned at any time so
what I was able to do was to look at
what people use that sort of this health
form I was talking about the sort of the
innovation I diffused through the
networks
once they adopted it they could keep
returning sort of many times if they
wanted to so able to look at these
returns business as they say finance
commitment you can ask the question how
many return visits were there by people
who got different numbers of signal
because people who adopt after one
signal at kind of baseline meet you like
your early adopters only twelve percent
of them ever came back so the vast
majority almost 90% of people who
adopted from one signal never really use
this and they kind of signed up look at
it and then never came back so getting
reinforcement signals make a difference
for commitment and the answer again made
a huge difference there's a dramatic and
interestingly increasing effect of
getting more reinforcing signals as part
of the diffusion process on people
subsequent engagement and like
potentially to keep returning to using
the health form and so what this tells
us in today's age there's really
interesting lesson that reinforcement is
not just a kind of a method for
spreading something that's difficult
accomplishment agents the mechanisms
that make something complex that they
need for credibility or we need for
intimacy but actually once they're
triggered once you have enough
reinforcements generate credibility or
enough reinforcement to generate
legitimacy thirty
mechanisms actually keep you committed
to something because of course now you
believe it's legitimate or now you
believe it's credible so you're gonna
keep using it as new options come along
and so the sort of mechanisms for
complexity in particular at barriers to
adoption you can be confirmed as
necessary hurdles to overcome they
create sort of long term engagement now
a methodological one thing I want to
point out is that this study or one
thing that a lot of people think about
in the space of computational social
science is that is the relationship
between like observational data and you
know kind of a big data versus like
theoretical modeling agent based
modeling or mathematical modeling first
of these kinds of online experiment they
all seem to be a great method but how do
they fit together and what I want to
suggest is that this project really
articulates very clearly exactly how
they fit together in a very productive
way which is that they said it with
observational data which gave us very
effective insight we saw that we could
learn about diffusion by understanding
that they things tend to spread sort of
spatially but that contradicted our
intuitions about the strength of weak
ties so we had kind of a tension about
an empirical puzzle but the fact that
spatial diffusion since being a
regularity of a data but it didn't make
sense for our model so he cope with the
new theoretical model of compressed
adhesion and that give us a way of
understanding why we might see spatial
diffusion be so prevalent but then that
generates a very provocative hypothesis
hypothesis if you were to build
construct a community online even
without all of the kinds of relational
factors that we took they think of and
offline networks like you know aspect
and Hamas Lee long-term interactions
frequent interactions all the things
that we think of as important in bimbe
relationships in neighborhoods if we
were to create artificial networks
online the hypothesis of our theoretical
combo contagions model is that you would
actually be better off creating a kind
of spatial clustered topology online or
generating traffic using then you would
generate a kind of randomly connected
small welder
new prime model and that was what we
impressed me in the experiment for the
results of my experiment them give
really I think concrete insight into
what's going on in our observational
data but now it shouldn't stop there if
science works the way it's supposed to
then once we have a model and an
experimental test of that model we
should then be able to go back to
observational data and look at our
observational data in a new way and see
new things in it and this is exactly
what's happened in the last seven or
eight years since these papers came out
there's been a justice know hundreds of
studies on complementation so it's found
these really interesting results about
diffusion of agricultural technologies
in Africa and exercise routine spreading
smoking behavior among teams this you
know the spread of social media account
that's actual like the geographic spread
I mean literally geographic spread from
neighborhood to neighborhood in towns
around Boston and towns around San
Francisco of Twitter and Facebook and
then also online of course and some of
the most interesting stuff about online
diffusion is that when you look at
certain kinds of contagions like like
idioms they tend to spread like simple
contagion but if you ladie contagions
like clinical hashtag they can describe
a complex contagion because they're more
contentious people require social
reinforcement you don't want to adopt I
kind of contentious political hashtag
unless there's enough reinforcement we
convince you it's always doing that
thing to do if you don't want to start
to put them aflame war in your own
printer network or Facebook communities
and so we see the same exact dynamic of
complexity online and offline in the
same way
this is implications again what I was
saying before before social design you
can this one of the big problems here is
you've lots of young women who are
fundamentally alienness institutional
sources of health care those same young
women oh really well represented online
and one of the things you can think
about but you don't like HPV vaccination
or really any texture actually any
prevention and for sexually transmitted
infection is that this isn't something
necessarily one of the stress with their
family or their close friends in fact
it's kind of a stigmatized conflict so
one of the advantages of these online
space
you can create anonymity but
historically and memin II meant Greek
ties dimensions we don't know well
people you couldn't get reinforcements
from online you can do a very special
thing you can create reinforcing
networks that become the clustered
structure to generate wide bridges that
accounts to be anonymous at the same
time because you can generate these
communities where people don't have
personal information about each other
but nevertheless can get strong social
reinforcement we're adopting positive
behaviors so we've done this in a couple
places we first in this went on HPV
vaccination the health context but this
step obviously applies young health read
a paper in science they came out in June
that was about these kinds of dynamics
and tipping points for social change and
things like legalization or perspectives
about legalization of marijuana in about
same-sex relationships how there's
social norm and also about sexual
harassment and a really important topic
that we were looking at how changes new
social mores that the acceptability of
certain behaviors dish so dramatically
this way if it was so in this paper that
we can identify a literally an exact
tipping point at which once you've got
enough people pushing for social change
around 25 percent then they would
generate the should massive take off
process in the population as a whole
this is kind of a cute anecdote so this
cart kicked out by the Atlantic in about
Scientific American so got some media
coverage and of course it spread all the
way around the world as a piece of news
to me all the way to Russia and I don't
you know read Cyrillic but I put this
into Google Translate and it came out as
the scientists have found how many
people you need to organize the
successful revolution so we did not so
how to organize like you know a whether
that's a Bolshevik Revolution we said
specifically how social norms can change
and then applied that most recently in a
study that we published in PNAS about
three weeks ago and that study was
looking at how these same network
dynamics work in contexts where people
have like really entrenched reason
should lean what they're believing so
we're looking at people's opinions about
climate change and the blue people are
Democrats and they're red or Republicans
and we did was we had them all sort of
estimated the surgeons definitely a
climate change and
this play my guess is not okay for able
to show is that I putting people into
these sorts of community structures we
were able to dramatically improve their
ability to predict the accuracy they
went from about the Republicans went
from about sixty percent accuracy in the
baseline to 95 percent accuracy as did
the Democrats so both groups got more
accurate and less polarized they like
when potentially they were like
polarized in opposite directions but
equally inaccurate and after interacting
they both became accurate and also like
polarized so this isn't social networks
can work and function deserve generate
social learning even across sort of
entrenched plain lines on topics like
climate change I have two more slides
from Jonathan for four hours up I'm
going to bring the topic back to where I
started with the person intuitions
you're married talking about their
tables when I was talking about the
networks and I was talking about the
ways in which and we D networks we have
a certain kind of intuitive response
about how they're going to look but what
I tried to do is today in the talk is
convince you there's a different way
I've taken me about networks so with
that in mind which would be two networks
is better for you know spreading
behavior change and the point a you're
kind of always intuitively going to see
the networking laugh this fast because
there's a viral intuition that kind of
sits in the background and that's fine I
think it's AI think it's persistent and
to oh just be there just like what the
table but we should do now is use your
kind of scientifically learning
intuition to start interpreting what
you're actually seeing the think email
about the need for social reinforcement
from multiple sources and how about
person in the left-hand network that hub
needs many more sources of reinforcement
also think about the countervailing
influences from all the people who
haven't adopted and again see that
person left-hand side has got lots of
counter billing any points and so needs
more social reinforcement which makes
the network on the right the more
conducive ecology flex reading behavior
change of course this is mostly the case
and behaviors are costly unfamiliar or
requires some degree of complementarity
and this brings us to a notion of like
very much like behavior economist plug
about choice architectures way of
framing the information in the
situations that you
to generate specific behaviors we can
now think in the same way I just showed
you with the experiment ways of
designing social spaces the kind of
interactions people have in ways that
even though that the structure is
invisible people it nevertheless escapes
their experience to generate systematic
patterns of behavior changes means
they'll even think of social capital
like financial capital human capital
it's a resource that you can find people
to actually help them to make better
decisions so with that I'm happy to take
your question thank you very much ok um
thank you please forgive me if this is a
naive question but I was looking at your
list of things that are likely to change
social behaviors and rhetorically I saw
an awful lot on the appeals to Authority
and you mentioned appeal to emotion but
you didn't mention anything about
appeals to logic are those just so weak
that they don't matter I mean does
Aristotle and it's rhetoric from 2000
years ago beat out Conte in the entire
enlightenment right so remember that
we're talking about here is kind of a
behavioral mechanism whether or not
logic is a social phenomenon I think
it's a great philosophical topic as far
as my own experience with logic goes
intentional and exponential logic it's
fairly isolated experience when I do
they're convinced or one isn't what you
tend to find and this is best thinkers
work on more than your reasoning is that
particular when people have insurance
believe that information is largely
useful providing clear you know even
regimented argumentation is largely
useless people aren't consistent the
standards of logic are much higher than
people's own standards for their for
their behavior and so one of the
fallacies I think of science
communication has been if you just give
people the right information then no
matter what to do and we've seen this
with vaccination where it's just not
true you have late they're in Marin
County
you've got the massive anti-vaxxer
movement we've got lots and lots of
really good information about how they
vaccinations are and also about the
dangers of not vaccinations of not
vaccinating for generate the digital age
basically huge gaps in herd immunity
like you're not just making your own
community more vulnerable you're making
everyone more vulnerable right there's a
lot of good science on this and there's
a lot of good information diffusion on
this it's completely ineffective at
changing one's mind because it's become
normative way entrench need to think
about what is it more and why is it
different than a piece of good
information or a piece of sound
reasoning well ones are often in many
cases appeals to emotion or their
appeals legitimacy or their appeal to
retentive like confidence that comes
with credibility but social proof that's
it I mean that's not good more and right
it's going to actually approve any real
sense it's meant to be a kind of a pond
so what it means is that there's enough
evidence in the sense that I get enough
reinforcement but I feel personally
convinced but that sense of convincement
isn't in any sense logical it's just a
kind of an emotional trigger that people
then feel like there's enough evidence
that they feel as though it's a safe
behavior or it's a legitimate behavior
or it's somehow a moral a good behavior
or two behavior there's more rewarding
for that complementarity and one of the
things I didn't talk about but with
emotional contagion was performing that
dynamic but so when you think about
behavior change and you think about the
differences between what's informational
exposure flavin reasoned argumentation
versus the kind of crowd movement we see
is like what the schooling analogy the
thing that generates behavior changes
people feel uncomfortable making choices
and that you know whether or not that
comfort has got to by to get an ideal
kind of asanas world that comfo would be
chided by logic but you know in an
empirical work their emotional world
where people are predictably irrational
those kinds of places are largely not
guided by logic okay and and if I only
have one more you feel static networks
most of your arcs were static are any of
them have you done any research on how
the networks may change as a result of
behavior
savvy paper published in 2014 or 2015 on
basically doing the same kind of
replicating experiment design so one of
the problems with a lot of the
observational studies is you watch one
massive network change but it doesn't
give you any evidence about how you know
what patterns are reproducible because
there's so many things there at ease in
chronic in one large data set so what I
did was I created a community and then
gay people from health buddies and then
gave them this sort of opportunity over
the course of seven weeks to just
basically add and drop limiting one to a
drop but I had I think seven or six six
different communities side-by-side so I
could dude wait Disney Washington and
Tehran see how they evolved and you saw
some really consistent pattern the
basically generated patterns of local
clustering patterns are from Offaly and
that wind up being a very good signature
of like how people want to choose
generate patterns of network
configuration that look very similar to
offline networks it's very interesting
because I think that there's this
fantasy that the online space will
generate this sort of you know these new
and interesting topologies of
connectedness will be so great that you
see that people kind of delegate and
crop a line in ways that they feel
comfortable with and those levels of
comfort are largely you know entrained
by institution or evolutionary cultural
memory where we kind of know the sort of
people we want to interact with and we
find those same sorts of people online
if you can see this in kind of
prophesies now they're studying I wanted
to edit technical sort of add on to your
question if you want to study a
diffusion process and your hypothesis is
if the ecology and network controls that
process then you don't want you you need
to network to be static as a scope
condition of our model right the theory
requires that you need otherwise you
don't know whether the network spreading
the diffusion or the cheating is
creating network right so that's why I
use static networks for those particular
demonstration okay thank you
you